do you think that that that
misinformation should be
actively
repressed by social media platforms they
should be making these judgments or are
you a view of more the view of an elon
musk that it should be more of a
a free debate i do think that people who
own platforms have a role there and
eventually the platforms tried to play
that role
uh
you know they
it was kind of too late and when you
don't have the trusted leaders you know
speaking out about vaccines it's pretty
hard for
the platform to
to work against that so i think we have
a leadership problem
and we have a platform problem so do you
have any advice for elon musk um you
as he buys twitter of what he should do
on this
well
you know he actually could make it worse
uh
that's not his track record i mean his
track record with tesla and spacex is
pretty mind-blowing at putting together
a great team of engineers and you know
taking the
people who worked in those fields
in a less bold way
and really showing them up
i i kind of doubt that'll happen this
time but we should have an open mind and
never underestimate elon
uh
you know what's his goal where he talks
about the openness
um you know how does he feel about
something that says vaccines kill people
or
you know that bill gates is tracking
people is that one of the things he
thinks should be spread so it's still
it's not totally clear what he's going
to do is
big risks with a platform like that
that's so pivotal for speech and ideas
and society a good idea
it's possible that because he
you know he he took big risks in spacex
and tesla they both were in periods
of uh financial stress where he went
full speed ahead and
uh you know came through that the fact
that he didn't buy twitter to make money
means that if there's something great
that can be done if it
all if all you need is money and hiring
great engineers he's probably as good a
person as any or his goals for what it
ends up being doesn't match
this idea of less extreme
uh falsehood spreading so quickly weird
conspiracy theories does he share that
goal or not uh
you know i thought that just human
judgment
would work um and so far
at least under the stress of the
pandemic
that hasn't stopped the crazy stuff from
getting out and kind of resonating with
people in terms of it's a much simpler
explanation
to say that you know this person started
the pandemic then that there's this
weird thing in biology where viruses the
talking of crazy stuff he's tweeted
about you recently a little bit i mean
how do you
that doesn't bother me and are you
shorting tesla i mean that's his sort of
underlying
concern it's impossible that the stock
went down and whoever sorted the stock
made money i don't know uh
did it go down in the last month i have
not been following
i don't i don't think the other one's
short or long tesla
it is you know a statement about your
seriousness about climate change i'm
putting billions of dollars into climate
change innovation i applaud tesla's role
uh in helping with climate change uh
and you know i have nothing but positive
things to say about elon
um if he met if he makes twitter more is
fine i'll speak out about that but i i
wouldn't assume that okay what's gonna
happen